after Toy Story 3 is almost perfect
ending Pixar's brought the toys back for
a sequel that's positively bursting with
Easter eggs and amazing hidden details
the movie has callbacks and deep cut
references to every single Pixar film so
far
yippie ki movie lovers I'm John and in
this video I'll be helping you navigate
the maze of Pixar Easter eggs in jokes
and crucial details you might have
missed in Toy Story 4 there are some
mild spoilers ahead though I avoid
discussing any major plot points and the
new Toy Story giveaway just started on
this video so subscribe hit the bell and
let me know which Easter eggs you
spotted for a chance to win let's kick
things off with a nostalgic Easter Egg
to up when woody reunites with Bo Peep
at the carnival when both sheep give her
a bottle top look closely as it's a
grape soda pin that Ellie gave Carl when
they were kids you and me we're in a
club now Carl also gave the pin to
Russell at the end of that movie and
it's a nice touch by Pixar to include it
in Toy Story 4 when woody and Bo reunite
and it links back to the love that Carl
and Ellie shared in Earth and powering
both skunk car are some BNL batteries
BNL aka by and large is a corporation in
wall-e that basically enabled the
pollution of the planet and sent humans
away from Earth while it attempted to
clear it up
Pixar always includes an Easter Egg to
its next movie and for onward you'll
need to look carefully among the various
attractions at the carnival there's a
stand called Dragon Zone which also has
a little dragon on its banner Blasi down
at sardis i didn't get a chance to
walker bad dragon back to layer kicks
our famous Pizza Planet truck has also
been hidden at the carnival in a very
curious way keep your eyes focused on
the carnival worker who runs the game
booth where duckie and bunny of prizes
you can see the truck for just a split
second as a tattoo on the back of his
leg in this scene where he knocks buzz
over by the way the official art of Toy
Story 4 book shows that the design of
the Pizza Planet truck tattoo is styled
in a similar fashion to the flaming
targets at the carnies game booth the
Pizza Planet truck appeared in the very
first Toy Story movie and is a regular
Pixar Easter Egg
The Stand also has lots more Easter eggs
hidden among the toys there's a couple
of tiny red and white rockets attached
to a toy planet for the similar looked
in the iconic red and white Pizza Planet
rocket from the Pizza Planet restaurant
in the first Toy Story movie another
similar rocket design also appears on
some of the caps of the game booth there
are also several taiga tars with designs
and patterns similar to the guitar that
Miguel took from Ernesto that accrues
from mausoleum in Cocoa other prizes
includes some rockets labeled x99 and
not to Toy Story 2 which was released in
1999 and the red star on a yellow circle
with blue stripes to the side is a
little luxo ball Easter Egg the full
look so ball appears in the antique shop
and I'll be getting that Easter Egg very
shortly the green frog here also looks
very similar to one of the garbage truck
toys that Lotso joined when he was
picked up by the driver at the end of
Toy Story 3 Toy Story 4 has an
interesting connection with the Pixar
short toy story of Terror by the shipit
truck which you can spot parked outside
the antique store ship it was the
delivery company that was picking up
packages from the sleepwell motel in Toy
Story of terror but it's also the same
truck that combat Carl and some other
toys hopped onto in the shorts closing
credits to escape from Ron the motel
manager who was stealing toys to sell
them on the Internet
next up Billy's house this one's tricky
to spot but the same wooden cart plus
balloons that Carl from up had when he
was a balloon salesman appears at the
carnival
also at the carnival is a truck with a
clown painted on the side a reference to
the 1987 Pixar short film red stream
when woody and the gang open up a hatch
on the roof of the antique store the
famous Pixar luxo ball appears on the
floor below them for just a split second
the luxo ball is a regular Pizza easter
egg and an homage to the Animation
Studios first short film look so junior
inside the store is a veritable
cornucopia of vintage objects and Pixar
Easter eggs there's a box of Casey jr.
cookies which were used in a books life
as wagons to transport PT flea circus
and of course they're also a Disney
reference to the steam train which
transported the circus in DUMBO next to
the Casey jr. cookies is the diving mask
that belonged to the dentist in Finding
Nemo and Carl's came from up is also
there hidden away on an upper shelf
where's my cane I just had it on the
wall in the store is a painting that
references are seen in up where Russell
passes a group of dogs playing poker in
this painting Charles Munson dug the dog
have also been added to the gambling
table by the way the original scene in
Earth was itself a reference to a famous
series of paintings of dogs playing
cards which were commissioned to
advertise cigars also hanging on the
wall is an unlit sign for Dinoco the oil
company and gas station that's appeared
in Pixar films including the Toy Story
in cars movies Bonnie and her family
also stopped for gas at a diner code
during their road trip it's tricky to
see but there's a miniature black Ford
Model T toy on one of the shelves are
not - Lizzie from the Cars movies you
can spot another cars reference on a
license plate during the forky rescue
attempt this carb county short for
carburetor County which is where
Radiator Springs is located and above
the license number is talk fill another
location in the Cars universe as the
toys flee from Gabby Gabby's
ventriloquist dummies they fly past an
old-looking square box with the word
pixar on it this is a vintage 80s Pixar
image computer a graphics machine
developed by the company back in the
days when it belonged to Lucasfilm you
can also see it to use as a logos or
Pixar's older short films when both
slides through Gabby Gabby's cabinet
there's a commemorative plate with a
symbol that fans of Pixar's brave will
recognize as the sword symbol represents
King Fergus and Meredith clamp when beau
takes woody to meet Duke kaboom inside
the store they go to a secret toy
hangout inside a pinball machine the art
of Toy Story for book shows that the
arcade machine is called Tiki party a
reference to the Tiki heads inside the
fish tank from Finding Nemo and there
are some great Easter eggs inside the
pinball machine
the first one is tinny
one-man-band player who originally
appeared in the 1998 pixar short film
tin toy tin ii was actually going to be
one of the main protagonists at the
original Toy Story movie until it was
decided the toy was too old-fashioned
and he was replaced by burst Lightyear
also inside the toy hangout are a couple
of vintage Star Wars toys for obi-wan
Kenobi and Ponda Baba the wonderful
thing about this particular Easter Egg
is that if you look very carefully
obi-wan Kenobi is repeatedly striking
ponder barber on the arm with his
lightsaber in an also a large the
original Star Wars Cantina scene where
obi-wan sliced off the walrus man's arm
and there may be another Star Wars arm
loss reference when woody accidentally
pulls Beau's arm off Franklin the toy
bald eagle from the Toy Story short
small fry is also inside the pinball
machine frankly was part of the
discarded fun Meal toys support group in
that short so it makes sense he's with
the group of lost toys in Toy Story 4
but I thought the kids liked me I'm like
history but on my old foe and woody
finally get to meet Duke kaboom the
Canadian stuntman toy who previously
appeared in Jack Jack's crib as an
easter egg and Incredibles 2 when Duke
kaboom does the jump from the ferris
wheel he passes across the moon and a
little homage not just to et but also to
were mated at a similar jump through the
air in the first Cars movie Duke kaboom
is voiced by Keanu Reeves and it's an
especially fitting role for the actor is
not only his Reeve starred in many
action movies including John wick The
Matrix and speed but he's also a keen
motorcyclist
and even co owns a company that makes
custom motorcycles Duke kaboom Canada's
greatest stuntman oh yeah ha ha yes and
as kaboom Reeves also gets to deliver
his famous whoa line from Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure in the movies mid
credits for more on Toy Story fours post
credits check out the second part of my
Easter Egg guide which are linked to at
the end of this video
as for the voice of the TV announcer on
the Duke kaboom commercial that's flee
from the Red Hot Chili Peppers
the a113 Easter Egg is a regular Pixar
one that proved a little tougher than
usual to spot in Toy Story 4 compared to
previous movies where it's often simply
appeared on license plates or written on
walls this time you'll see it in second
chance antiques which is a vintage 70s
style sign the appearance of a113 in
Pixar's films is a tribute to the
classroom at California Institute of the
Arts where many of Pixar's animators
studied other vintage sign Easter eggs
to look out for in the store include
this one 4 year old poultry palace
poultry palace is the chicken restaurant
that featured in the Toy Story tooned
short small fry and in Toy Story for
Bonnie and her family also visit the
fast food chain during their road trip
there's an old record player in the
antique store with Anna nested that
accrues Greatest Hits record keep your
eyes peeled for a vintage ad for triple
dance which is the brand of chewing gum
with that very memorable jingling inside
out the sound from the gum commercial
know sometimes we send that one up to
headquarters for no reason there's also
a classic Eggman moving company sign in
the antique shop and Easter Egg - the
Eggman movers who appeared in the first
Toy Story film and as Vincent the
ventriloquist doll wheels Gaby Gaby
woody and forkie away and old record
starts playing the song is midnight the
stars in you which played at the end of
the shining the for numerous tributes to
director Stanley Kubrick's classic movie
and Pixar's films over the years
including the carpet and since housed in
the first Toy Story movie and various
references to the horror films creepy
room 237 whose vilasa star 2/3 settle
down street that's nothing let me just
take care of that
and there's another Kubrick on Marge
when buzz presses one of its buttons and
his inner voice says open the pod bay
doors which is a famous line from 2001 a
Space Odyssey ducky and bunnies fantasy
sequences about how to get the key from
the antique store owner a particularly
hilarious what about the old plush rush
there you go did you do
well we're not doing that and in another
scenario when the old lady opens her
fridge at home we get a glimpse at
another regular Pixar Easter Egg the
Chinese takeout box the box has a very
specific design and has appeared in the
back of the Pizza Planet truck in Toy
Story 2 in Inside Out Monsters Inc
ratatouille and also Incredibles to its
first appearance was in a bug's life
where it was called the Chinese cabinet
it's more there's a ton more Pixar
objects in second chance antiques and
I'll run through a quick list of some to
look out for elastic girls a lastest I
call from Incredibles 2 can be seen as a
toy in the store there's also one of the
Monsters Inc scream canisters for sale
and there's a bear carving from brave
the house from Earth which Carl so
memorably took on a balloon journey has
been shrunk down into a doll's house and
is now for sale Bing bongs rocket from
inside out also appears plus their board
games for to Pixar shorts nicknack and
lifted the antique store itself is also
a double Easter Egg firstly the address
is 1200 a reference to 1200 Park Avenue
in Emeryville the address of Pixar
Animation Studios and second chance
antiques was founded in 1986 the same
year Pixar was spun out as a separate
corporation from Lucasfilm
we've also got some very cool Easter
eggs to talk about from the movies
opening flashback scene plus an
intriguing change that Pixar made to Toy
Story 4 that could completely debunk the
Pixar theory those will all be in the
second part of this video add the link
here and in the video description for
you to watch as soon as it's ready
so which Easter eggs did you spot in Toy
Story 4 and are there any I missed share
your thoughts in the comments below and
be sure to subscribe to enter the toy
story giveaway congratulations to the
winner of my Aladdin giveaway email me
from my about page so I can send you the
prize and if you enjoyed this do hit
that thumbs up button and tap left to
watch the second part of this video or
tap write for more Pixar or other videos
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time yippie Kay we'll
be lovers